And here we go. Hello, everybody, Dr. Kevin Cutters, and today we're going to talk about lymphatic
congestion first. So lymphatic congestion is a real problem with a lot of people, not just with
patients with cancer. So let's talk about that. First of all, what is our limb system? So our limb
system, you have lymph nodes, everybody's heard of lymph nodes, especially if you had cancer because
maybe you had some of them removed. And you have lymph vessels. Your lymph vessels are best maybe
described. I like to describe them as kind of open-ended sewer systems. They're open-ended
capillaries that drain your extracellular space, extra outside cellular space. So the space between
the cells has to be drained because your cells have metabolic processes that are going on, all sorts of
different things happening inside that cell. Remember, I said, think of a cell is like New York City,
all these millions of different events that are taking place that produce a lot of waste. And the
cells give that waste off into the space between the cells. That's the extracellular fluid,
which can become very viscous. It's not fluid. So that's why you don't just cut yourself open and use
water all over. It's very viscous material that is drained by open-ended capillaries. And I think
they're best described as like your storm sewers on the street. So when it rains, really hard
is would be considered maybe as your cells are giving off waste, that waste that runs down
into the sewer system. The sewer system could be best described as the vessel itself. And then it's
carried through the lymph vessel ultimately back to the arteries. But it goes through these things
called lymph nodes, which are concentrated areas of a lot of white blood cells, macrophages, T cells,
lymphocytes, to kill anything that's in that waste. Because we don't want to be putting bacteria
back in dumping that back into the bloodstream, the vascular system. So we certainly don't want that
to go back into the vitis circulation that's going to cause disease elsewhere in my body. So the lymph
nodes kill any infections. It's not going to kill any toxins, but it's going to kill any infections.
And if the toxins that are dumped out of the cell into the extracellular space picked up by the
open-ended capillaries, the storm sewers, carried through the duct system, the lymph vessels,
go through the lymph node, kills off any bacteria or viruses that are in there, then goes dumps it
into the venous system, which then goes through your liver and helps filter out any toxins,
so your liver, your kidney, help get rid of the toxins that are in that lymph that's carried out
of your extracellular spaces. So that's the purpose of the lymph system is to clean your body.
So if we didn't have storm sewers and we lived in a city and it rained six inches,
we'd have water backed up in our yards and be backed up into our basement to make a mess,
we would become toxic if that had no way to get out of our body. So we would become toxic very quickly. So
the idea sometimes in the practice medicine as far as oncology goes is, well your lymph system
carries things around your body and well if we have, let's say, breast cancer, those breast
cancer cells can go into the extracellular space and through the lymph system to the rest of the body,
so maybe we should remove the scent in the load, we know we should remove any lymph nodes if we get rid
of all the lymph nodes, then the cancer cells, the tumor circulated tumor cells can't go through the
body. I guess that makes sense in one sense of thinking, but the problem with that is by the time
your cancer got to the size that you're even considering surgery to remove the cancer and let alone
the lymph nodes, you've already passed millions of circulating tumor cells around your body. So
in that understanding it makes no sense to remove all your lymph nodes. I'm not saying that a person
shouldn't remove a lymph node that is cancerous, but when a person has lymph nodes near a cancer site
and then the debulking of the cancer surgically occurs and the surgeon decides to take
5, 10, 20, 30, 40 lymph nodes out to test them to see if they're cancerous and then two or three
of them are cancerous, you removed a lot of your drainage possibilities. And when you remove the storm
sewers, that's when we can have the problem with backup and that's where we have the problem with
lymph congestion. So there's other reasons why it will go over that. So if a person didn't have any
surgery, didn't remove any lymph nodes or lymph vessels and it's still having lymph conjecture, we'll
talk about why that might be. But certainly I don't agree with the idea of removing a whole bunch of
lymph nodes to see if they're cancerous. The problem is when you're looking at from a surgeon's point of
view, you can't see if something's cancer, so that's it's grossly grown cancer around that
lymph node. It can be just, you know, thousands and thousands of cells inside the lymph node still
as invisible. It has to be millions and millions and millions of cells to be large enough to be visible.
So they're not, from their understanding, it's like, well, we don't know if that is cancerous,
we're going to remove it. They're just trying to take this scorched earth approach to getting rid of
your cancer and it can leave a person. And sometimes it'll worst case scenario afterwards, but their
thought is, well, we're just trying to save this person's life. So your lymph system is vessels. So you
got vessels and nodes. So let's talk about the vessels first. So again, think of the vessels, the
open and capillary draining that extracellular space back into the bloodstream, cleaning it out. It's
like it's your drainage system. So the issues that you could have is you could have blocked vessels.
So what could block your vessels? Access waste could block the vessels. Exotoxins could block the
vessels. Large proteins, large particles, large toxins could block the vessels. So different things
could happen to block those vessels to cause extra lymph swelling. Downs are upstream from that.
So when we're talking about lymph swelling, we're usually talking backstream or upstream from the
lymph vessels, because the lymph vessels are draining it. Damaged vessels. So I could have damaged
vessels from surgical damage or surgical removal of lymph nodes and vessels. I can have
damaged vessels from wounds. So this is what I was talking about. So if I have re, if I have surgery
to debalk a cancer, and then I have surgery to debalk multiple lymph nodes or remove my septal lymph
nodes, then I'm going to have backup upstream. I'm not going to drain that area very well at all.
That's going to be an issue. And it's sometimes difficult to overcome. I can also have compression
unbassles downstream. So compression is what I never had surgery. So why am I getting lymph swelling
and excess, excess swelling in the tissue when I've never had surgery surgery? So even a person that
sits all day at work, you have compression. So let's get to a picture of how my lymph system drains.
Let's jump down here. So my lymph system drains this way. So let's say I get swelling in my legs
because I take off my socks at night and my goodness, I can see the lighting of my socks on my
ankles. Why is that? I'd ever had surgery. I'd ever had any lymph nodes removed. My lymph vessels are
still intact. I don't have a large cancer growing in my abdominal area that is blockied. Why
would that possibly be? That's an opportunity to have cancer. They have swelling in their legs.
Well, can be due to diet. We're not going to get into the diet and salt issue of this talk,
but we're talking about blockage. It can be due to compression. So a person sitting all day,
these vessels have to drain back up here into the inferiorivated cave in the abdominal cavity to
get back to the heart. So if there's compression in the in the in the iguana area in your
legs and hips area from citadel, that can be an issue. Also, the lymph system does not have a heart
that pumps fluid through these vessels. So let's go back to a picture here. So the way that the water
runs in your storm sewer is simply by gravity. So water is so if you have a storm sewer that's
on the top of the hill, that would make no sense. You put the storm sewer at the bottom of the hill
so water can run down the hill and go into the storm sewer. Otherwise, we're going to have a big
puddle of water at the bottom of the hill. Well, sometimes that's what takes place with our legs.
We're sitting all day. We're not getting up walking around because it is actually the contraction
of the muscles that pushes the fluid through the veins. How is the fluid going to exit my feet down
here? If I'm standing all day or sitting all day and get back up to my heart, I don't have,
my blood system has my arteries that blood is pushed through my arteries, then through my veins
back up to my heart, but my limb system doesn't have a heart. It relies completely on the contraction
of the muscles in order to push the fluid through those limb vessels. The limb vessels have
little valves in them. One way valves through the fluid could only go one way, but it is very dependent
upon contraction of the muscles to push the fluid through those vessels. So even a person has
completely intact vessels and no blockage upstream, they could get swelling because they're not
contracting their legs. They're not moving their legs. They're not, they're getting compression
from sitting all day or something like that. So it's very valuable to get up, walk around, do some
leg toe raises, contraction of your muscles. If you're sitting all day, write the alphabet with your
feet, move your muscles, contract muscles, move your body in order to get that compression off and
get the vessels moving the fluid through the vessels themselves, using the muscles.
That issue is that you can have with the lymph nodes themselves. So a lymph node can be swollen
and it can be hypertrophied, and we want to kind of distinguish the two things a little bit. So
often when we're used to treat a lot of kids, the parents would say, my son has got a large lymph nodes
in their neck, typically after a cold or a flu or some sort of virus that they had, the parent
was all concerned because this lymph node was rather large in the person's neck. So back to a picture
of lymph nodes, you have all these lymph nodes in your head and neck and under your jaw and down
your neck and that's what drains your head. So if this child has a really bad head cold, that virus
is going to drain down and that fluid is going to drain down those posterior cervical and anterior
cervical lymph nodes and you can get a giant and large lymph node. So a lymph node can enlarge
or hypertrophy because it's increased the amount of lymph tissue in the lymph node. In the case of
bad infection, your lymph node can enlarge hypertrophy because you're adding a lot more white blood
cells to be able to kill that infection that's there. And sometimes in children, it never goes down
and they just grow into it. Sometimes it'll take months for that lymph node to go down. Never should
you massage that lymph node itself. Never should you try to push on it or try to worry about pushing that
lymph node or touching that lymph node to get it to go down in any way. So leave it alone that
lymph node is enlarged for a reason. Many times in good reason, there's a lot more white blood cells
there to help kill off any infection that is going through it. Remember the lymph node is killing any
infection from the toxins or the viruses or the bacteria that are going through the lymph vessels.
So a swollen lymph node can be from a different reason. So the lymph node can be swollen,
typically you see that in adults, because of upstream waste. So if a person is, let's say they have
breast cancer. And now they have swollen or large lymph nodes in their axillary area, in their armpit.
And they're concerned whether is this a swollen lymph node or a hypertrophy lymph node. So when we
talk about hypertrophy lymph node, we're talking about post infection. Okay, so can a woman get
hypertrophy lymph node in her ax and a post infection in her breast from breastfeeding? Yes,
you can, but it will typically disperse within a few weeks and there won't be an issue. A swollen
lymph node is from clearing waste from an area. So let's say a person back to the breast cancer example
has a swollen lymph node after doing chemotherapy. That's not that uncommon because chemotherapy kills
cancer cells via lysis. And killing via lysis is going to produce a lot of exotoxins, which
is going to have to be carried away and they can get a swollen lymph node because of that. Again, I'd say
maybe it's good to just leave that alone and let your body clear that out. Work downstream from there
to help clear that out. Second reason why you could get swollen lymph nodes or large lymph nodes is
pathological enlargement of a lymph node. So a lymph node can enlarge pathologically because there's
cancer in that lymph node. And that's what we're concerned with with any history of cancer. So always
with any history of cancer, we tend to jump to that conclusion. I got a symptom by my neck hurts,
do I have cancer in my neck? Well, I guess it's not wrong to jump to that conclusion because we're
trying to be safe and safe as possible in our differential diagnosis given our history that we have.
But it's not always the right answer. So it's not always the reason why we have a symptom. But when
we have a large lymph node near the site of the cancer, that's always a concern because is that
a chance that the cancer is growing more in the lymph node? That's a possibility. That's where the
only way to know diagnostically for sure is to get a biopsy of that lymph node to know if that's
what's going on. So what do we do about these things? So first of all, if you have blocked vessels,
we want to know why or damage vessels, why or downstream compression, why? Because there can be some
pathological things that are going on with that as well. A person can have issues from city to
and inflammation in the blood vessels as well, especially in the venous system that really needs to be
addressed and many times antibiotics are in order. So you do want to know why this is going on. You
want to ask me those questions, why? Understand the anatomy at least. So understand the main points
in the lymph system. You can compress a lymph vessel. The lymph vessels have very little contractile
tissue in the vessels themselves. So they're easily compressed and blocked. The only way fluid moves
and waste moves through the vessels is through the action either of gravity, which is a bad way for a
lymph to move through it. Or the best way is through contraction of the muscles. So if you have
swelling of the legs or the hands or anything, make sure you start by making sure there's no compression
that is moving your body, getting some motion in your body and getting some muscle contraction. Do muscle
just some little calisthenic type exercises. It can be anything from pushing up against a wall to
doing leg razors to writing the alphabet with your feet and then with your legs. Just get your body
moving. You don't have to go for a 10 mile walk. Just get your body moving. Now that you can do,
we've talked, there's other people that have talked about doing lymphatic massages. It isn't safe to
do a lymphatic massage. Yes and no, you do have to be careful doing lymphatic massage. You'd
want to go to make sure that you go to a massage therapist who is really specializes in lymphatic
in cancer massages. So we used to have a massage therapist that worked for us, that worked for a
few years ago. And she went and got some extra training in cancer and dealing with cancer patients.
I think it's important to make sure that the massage therapist, because there's a lot of different
schools of massage therapy out there and maybe some that don't get a great education that you don't
massage the lymph node, nowhere do you try to press on an area that's too close to cancer. So you just
make just be careful of that. We've had people say they've got a lymphatic massage that was terrific
and other people say they went to a massage therapist who's going to horrible, then they felt worse
afterwards. Just be careful who you're going to. And then there's some nutrition that you could use.
We have some lymph stem lacquessons and some lymphoconpone and then there's another supplement that we have
that's probably very underused. It's called proherb diuretic. It's an herbal diuretic to help
the body flow. And you can use medicinal drug diuretics as well, back to get fluid moving out of your
body too. But I'd always like to go an herbal approach if we can do that. If you have swollen
lymph nodes, you can still use any of those therapies as well. And then there's other things you
could do, support the pathways, other pathways of detoxification. Think of like using soda.
Remember, your lymph system is a way you detoxify your extra cellular spaces. Now it's going to bring
it back to the bloodstream and then the bloodstream is going to bring it to the liver and the kidneys.
So you're going to be stressing the liver and the kidneys, the more toxins or the more detoxification
that you're doing. So if you could use the foot bath, a soda,
castor oil packs can help. Coffee edemas can be extremely beneficial.
Heat and can you use heat right over a node? Yes, but be careful of the temperature that you're
using. Make sure you're not getting too high of heat. Also be careful, a little caveat here. Be
careful with the heat pads that you're using. Even if you're using those nice jade or
turbulent heating pads that are infrared heating pads, you can burn yourself with them. So be
careful with that. And especially if you fall asleep or something, make sure you put a towel underneath
that or put some clothing underneath that. So it's not a direct skin. You don't want to burn your
skin. Be careful with that. Essential oils can be beneficial too. And there's many different
essential oils to try. We typically tell people make sure that you use a carrier oil.
Hot oils can be caused sensitivity on the skin. CBD oil can be really beneficial.
I didn't put on here. DMSO can be really beneficial as well. And again, I can't overemphasize
exercise and getting motion. So getting it up and moving, getting some exercise,
getting that muscle contraction is going to be really good. Changing your sleeping position.
Many times it's a person's sleeping position that's causing the issues.
City position. Avoiding compression meaning being in one position at any time. You could use
compression upstream. That means like compression socks using gravity to your benefit.
I've even had people get on the floor on all fours like you're going to crawl around on your
knees and your hands. It just relax your tummy. So all the lower extremity lymph nodes have to
drain into the abdominal cavity. And they drain into and ultimately empty into the the vet,
the beta system called the inferior beta-cava that drains back to your heart. And if you have any
fluid in your abdominal cavity or if you have a mass, a tumor mass in your abdominal cavity,
that's putting pressure down on the inferior beta-cava. So while I'm laying on my back
and I'm raising my legs, my legs are raised so that you think would be good because
I have it in an anti-gravity position, so my legs should drain. But if I'm laying on my back
and my legs are raised and I have any fluid or any mass in my abdominal cavity,
that's going to put even more pressure on my inferior beta-cava. And nothing's going to drain
from my legs. So it's like why aren't my legs draining? Well, maybe the better thing to do
is to stand up and walk around and exercise and then get on all fours on your knees and your hands
and allow your tummy to sag so that it opens up your inferior beta-cava. Your vessels are just
soft tubes. They're not like hard, you know, mental tubes or hard plastic tubes. They're just
soft tubes. So you can push on them just like on the back of your hand, if you push on your vessel,
it just squashes down. Well, that's what takes place in your body. So any pressure on there for any
reason, like all my legs are swollen. Well, it's just a whole negative loop that you get into
because your swollen legs compress your lip system and don't allow the lip to drain through your
legs. So it just gets it's something that can get worse really quick.
So do we sell some questions that came into the chat? Do we have DMSO? Yes, we have the DMSO
with the ZIG. That DMSO ZIG spray that we that we use is the lymphatic drainage pattern the same
on both sides of the body. Now this picture shows it that it's the same on both sides of the body.
And here's a bigger picture of it, but it's not it doesn't actually go exactly like this.
Because actually the whole the whole person's right side of the body, the head the entire head
ultimately drains down to the right lymph node right above the breast and the and the right arm drains
to the right lymph node. And then the entire left side of the body and the right and the
abdomen and the right leg drains up to the left lymph node that's right above the breast. That's just
how it drains. This is a little bit different like that. But generally, this gives you an idea the
direction of lymph flow. This is correct in the direction of lymph flow. So it gives you a good picture
that way. Other things that you can do, check, you know, check in right frequency. So ultimately,
if the cancer is in the lymph node itself, what do we want to drain it? Yes, we want to make sure
that we get drainage, but we want to make sure that we're running the right frequency. So most of you know,
some of you don't know that Michelle and I are doing a constant, never-ending study
on what to do to help our patients. And one of the things that we've come up with the last couple
of months is adding a lot more frequencies to a person's program. So a lot of people's programs,
instead of being just a weak lung program are now turning into two or three week program that they're
that they're cycling every three weeks. They're running a different frequency. So they have an
ASET, Bset, a Monday, ASET Monday, Bset Monday, Cset, if it's a three week program. Because we're
testing for different frequencies that might be also beneficial for that person's cancer and that
can change. So you can ask about that. So if your cancer's going the wrong way and you're starting to get
more swelling, make sure you ask us, call us, ask us or Facebook us that you want us to check
and do some distance testing on you to check and see if adding some more frequencies would be
beneficial. And then we can send you a flash drive for you to update your RIFE program so that you can
get those new frequencies in. A second, they recheck in your supplements. It's always good if we're not
going to the right direction to make sure that we're doing the right thing. Do we need to add these
detox things or not? What do we need to do? And then using other therapies is the PEMF good. Yeah,
that can help with limb system flow. Absolutely. Can H5 help? Well, H5 is not going to necessarily
live flow, but it's going to help with other things. The LBG, the light beam generator, is one of the
tools that are, if every patient was local, I mean, if you have limb congestion, you're going to be
doing the LBG. That is, that is one of my favorite limb congestion tools. The other one I forgot to
put on here is the acoustic. The acoustic is great for limb congestion. So anybody's got really bad
limb congestion. Just moved to Minnesota, especially this time of year. It's just perfect. And we'll get
going to the LBG in acoustic. And I wish I could be completely serious about that because those
tools are really great tools for limb congestion for people. Question, are there lived drainage
frequencies in the custom rife programs? You said no, because there really isn't a lot of lived
drainage frequencies. But there are what when I talk about rechecking rife frequencies, it's to help
kill the cancer. So again, if I have cancer in a lymph node, and my lymph node is getting larger,
and it's not draining my tissue, or my cancer, and my abdominal cavity is getting larger, and that's
why my legs are draining, we have to fix the Y, remember. So fixing the Y is to see how we can,
any way we can tweak things, get more aggressive, any impossible way to help kill the reason why
the increased growth of the cancer. And that's why we would be checking the frequencies.
Question, is there any way to do the acoustic and the LBG at home? No, there isn't. The acoustic
therapy is completely cost preventative to do anywhere. I mean, that acoustic therapy equipment is
over $100,000. And the LBG, that's possible. Those are purchasable, used at a decent price,
new, they're $15,000, but you can't get them used. Sometimes, I've seen them on eBay. Sometimes,
not very often, but the LBG is a great therapy for lymphatic detoxification. Hypertherbias good,
that's where hot packs, cold packs, can be beneficial. Sometimes it's good to pulse hot and cold,
you put a hot pack on, then you put a cold pack on for two minutes, you put a hot pack on,
you put a cold pack on for two minutes. Sometimes pulsing the body can help move live better.
In other therapies, like IV vitamin C and ozone can be beneficial too, but really the most common
thing that's going to help with drainage is you have to deal with the reason why is their compression,
is their growth in the cancer. Secondly, is exercise in motion. Those are going to be the key
things to dealing with lymph congestion. Okay, I got to unmute everybody and open you up for questions.
So you are unmuted unless you muted yourself, which a few people I see did, which is just fine.
If you've got babies cry to the background, I appreciate that. But if you have a question,
make sure you hit your unmute and then you could give me your questions. Nobody? Does it have to be
on this topic? The Dr. Canoes, this is Janet Kisling. Yes. I'm so sorry. I was supposed to send you
questions and it just has not happened. But I am beginning to think that maybe some of my problems
have been that my body is having an allergic reaction to oregano because I've been using that
tooth and gum oil. Yep. And my gums are doing what they, what I have had in the past with
mer and I'm very allergic to mer. So I just feel like ripping my teeth out of my mouth. So that was
starting to happen and I started recognizing it. So I quit doing that oil. Good. My gums are
much better. Good. But then I started thinking about that the, because I've been still
dealing somewhat with the bladder issues. I've gotten it to go quite a bit. It's quite a bit better.
And so I started looking, I looked at the HPLR. It has oregano in it. Yes.
So if you have a sensitivity to oregano, you can't use that. So I took it out. I have not
heading of any of it since Saturday. And it's just, it's been getting better and better and better.
Oh, good. So you might have knocked the, the, the, the, the, H. Pylora, I owed already, but
they know you just have a sensitivity of oregano. Yeah, I don't know because I'm still dealing with,
okay, so I'm sitting here right now with a liver pack. And when I put the liver, the heat on my liver
like that, right in the areas where I still feel real, weird sluggishness like that snake feeling.
Okay. So the, the other way to kill the H. Pylora is to use just straight burberry.
Okay. And we have the burberry clear. I think I'm on burberry clear though.
Yes, you are, but just increase your dosage of that then. Okay. And then you can run the H. Pylora
frequencies are the right. Yes, I've been doing that. And I really do think that that helps too.
I, I've been trying to do that. It's just, yeah, takes a lot of time every day.
Okay. So, and I really appreciate what you had to say about this lymph,
the lymph, so I have a lymph node in my armpit, actually a couple of them that are quite,
you know, swollen up. And they were getting bigger and smaller.
But I feel like since I got my new frequencies that you sent, that definitely has,
there's definitely something that has happened that it's doing better. So I really appreciate that.
Well, that's good. Yeah. So thank you very much. I really appreciate it. And I'm still working through
these things. And I, and I thank you so much. Oh, you bet. Keep up the good work.
Hey, Dr. Connors, how are you? Good. How are you?
Feeling great. I had a question about, could I saw, I think Sharon asked about
IPT chemotherapy? Yes. And I was just kind of curious about, you know, IPT versus
full, why someone would go IPT or, you know, and then would IPT still have a lot of the residual
raise your chance per reoccurrence and things like that, that the full, you know.
So the benefit of IPT is just stemming off the cancer, all cancer, even if it's not, you know,
completely glycolidically driven, it's still going to, it's still going to uptake insulin.
So they're just taking that information and going, okay, well, why can't we just dose insulin to
this person and then give a smaller dose of the chemo right afterwards. And the chemo will just
drag right with the insulin into the cancer cell and we'll get the same effects on full dose chemo
by using a much lower dose chemo plus insulin. So all the studies and the
testimonials of patients doing this are mixed results. And I say mixed results, meaning that they're
really the same results as the person did full chemo, which are mixed results. So there's no,
there's no guarantee a person does chemo that the chemo is going to work. Why? Because the chemo
doesn't always work. So it just doesn't, it's just like anything else, it's just not always going to work.
So it will insulate potentially any chemotherapy work? No, it's not going to always work either,
because it's still using chemo as the killing agent. Now the question is, why would a person do,
a question really shouldn't be why would a person do insulin-potentiated chemo therapy? Why don't
they just do chemo? The question is, why would anybody do chemo? Why don't they just do insulin-potentiated
chemo? Because if it's going to work, it's going to work and they're not going to have all the side
effects. Right. So you're, well, you also have some side effects because it's still chemo, but it's
only about 10% of the chemo. So you're going to have much decreased side effects, much decreased,
you know, ill-effects-log term, than if you did full chemo. And, you know, by any mathematical
genius looking at case studies, you're going to have just as good a chance in success at insulin-potentiated
chemo therapy as you're going to have a chemo therapy. That's just the facts that are out there. So
if you're going to look at chemo, the best way to do it is to do insulin-potentiated chemo. Now the
other downside of doing insulin-potentiated chemo is that typically your insurance isn't going to
cover it, but if you do chemo, your insurance covers it. So that's usually the decision-making factor of
people. So where do I go get insulin-potentiated chemo therapy? That's another factor. Why people don't
do it? Oh, I have to go to Arizona to this clinic in Arizona and do it. Well, I want to work at the
same, you know, I could get chemo at my hospital down the street. So what am I going to do to get insulin-potentiated
chemo? It's still the same, it's still like to say protocol. So I have to go stay there for three
months. Yeah, you do, or you're going to fly back and forth. So there's all those type of factors
on why people don't do that. Cost, travel times, date where all those different things, but from a
health standpoint, oh, it's much easier on your body. You have just as good a chance of
it working as you would as the chemo working, and you're not going to have any of the side effects
are very few. Right, because I, you know, I feel like because, you know, my score jumps so much,
the tumor still seems to just be growing without really much, you know, stop, that I'm just kind of
starting to look into options like that. And I, you know, I was kind of wanting to know what you
thought about that. I have just recently been recommended a clinic in Atlanta called Advanced
Center for Medicine. I think Jonathan Stagle is the doctor there. I don't know if you're familiar
at all with that facility or anything. But I know that's what he does the low dose insulin-potentiated
chemo with dextrose or something. And then he does like PEMF and he does a lot of these other supportive
things. Yeah, there's just not that many critics that do that. So that that would be closer to you
that's a lot better. Yeah, that one's about four hours away. But I mean, we would have to, you know,
we'd have to stay stay down there and like a Airbnb or something like that. But we were kind of
starting to play with that just because I feel like I'm not get I'm going in the wrong direction.
You know, is it time to just up the aggressiveness to hopefully reverse? Or should I give it a little
more time? You know, I think the IV gene score was just would just kind of put me in a little more of a
like, hey, wait a minute. I didn't know, you know, why am I moving so fast in the wrong direction?
You know, it was such a big jump. So it was a little bit of a surprise.
That's where you're Steve to start asking those other questions. This is a do idea to do something
different. Right. Right. And that's what we've been asking. And you know, I really like chemo just
freaks me out because you hear all these like residual effects of it long term. So I'm like, can
I just do like IV therapies instead? You know, would that be enough? You know, but I I guess for
me to anytime I ask or consult with anybody outside of Connor's clinic, they're like triple negative.
You don't want to mess with that. It is the most aggressive cancer. It doubles overnight, you know,
or like in size and you just you really need to be serious about this. And it's it's kind of
intimidating, you know, to make decisions when you are constantly hearing that from other people.
So right. It is. But yeah, I just reached out. They said that I'd have to have a consultation.
And then they're pretty picky about who they accept. They want to they would want to make sure that
they feel like they could help me before they would accept me. And I would have to go get a
port put in surgically before I would be, you know, accepted at the clinic, basically. So I kind
of got the ball rolling on, but, you know, it's still a little intimidating. Yeah, it is.
Well, let us know what you find out about that. I will. Yeah, I know there's the other thing I was
going to ask was I've been looking at a San Diego clinic and they do a lot of vaccines. What are
do you have any thoughts opinions on all these cancer vaccines out there like dendrick cell? And I
mean, this clinic had listed like eight or nine different kinds like NK vaccine. And I don't
I don't even remember all of them. But have you is that like chemotherapy where it works on some?
It doesn't work on others. Well, it is like anything it can work on some people and not work
on others. And I think there's some there's some benefit to them on some people, but, you know, the
studies are really mixed on those. Yeah. Okay. So all right. So just be careful moving forward with
something like that probably. Yeah, just keep in contact with us and let us know. I will. Absolutely.
Thank you so much. And I really appreciated all the info on the lymph system that was super helpful.
Thank you. You bet. Dr. counters. This is Carol Shilchewski. Hi, Carol. Hi. I have a question. I've
had a lot of lung congestion. Could any of the supplements I'm using cause lung congestion?
The only thing that would cause lung congestion is like if you're sensitive to something.
Okay. Lug congestion like what? Well, I've had this congestion in my lung since about September.
And we saw that it was me detoxing and the toxins don't have anywhere to go. And then we found out
that my histamine, I have that defect for the histamine. And so I'm taking the histamine scavenger.
And it does help. But I noticed today I was in the interest. It helps quite a bit.
But I'm just wondering why all this lung congestion? I'm wondering.
What do you explain to me? What do you describe it as lung congestion like a cough?
A cough once in a while. I'm out of breath when I like go up and down the stairs.
If I do a brisk walk or something like that, I wheeze at night when I lay down sometimes in the
morning. When I get up and I walk around, it gets a little better. It's just kind of like a
heaviness almost. Because I've had asthma as a child, but it's not quite as bad as that.
And when I cough, nothing comes up. Okay. So we really need to do a differential diagnosis.
And that's what that is. So weezy is a constriction of the bronchioles.
And that could be because of sensitivity and maybe.
Usually, you know, sensitivity is to something you're taking supplement or something like that.
It's going to be more gut issues. But I can look at what I have you on again and I'll
read out, analyze that and see what could be possibly added to that. If you had it for this
lug, then you don't think so much of an infection. As it gotten worse, or is it just kind of stay the same?
It times it can get worse. It just depends. Some nights are worse than others. If I take more,
the histamine scavenger that helps. Okay. So if you take more of the histamine scavenger that helps
then you think, okay, what is causing it to increase histamine reaction? How about mold in your house?
No mold in my house. Okay. Let me think about that a little bit. Okay.
And then I was going to get a nebulizer and have silver put silver in it. Yeah.
Colloidal silver to maybe help that. Yes. Well, colloidal silver would help it only if there's an infection.
Okay. So. I think the worry is that it cushioned because it's always congested.
Try to think what else you could nebulize. You could try it. Do it.
Nebulized colloidal silver. That's fine. I can't hurt you. Right. The other thing
is wonder if getting a air purifier with ozone will be beneficial too. Like those ones we have in our
office. Yeah. Just buy them on Amazon and put it that in your house. And especially if it's
worse at night in your bedroom still could be something in the air that you're sensitive to. Something
is causing a histamine reaction of some kind. Yeah. I noticed it like in September and I had started
on the detoxing in like end of June. Yeah. Let me think about that a little bit. I'll look at the
stuff that you're taking. Okay. Thank you. Okay. All right. Well, thanks everybody for participating.
We will get this up on the Facebook page. And we will talk to everybody next week. I'll be praying
for all of you. Oh, you have a question? Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. This is Claudia Wagner. I work at this
time. So I'm never on because I do. The question is that's okay with you. Oh, absolutely. Go ahead.
Okay. Thank you. So as I'm looking at where I am, the city I had the Navarro HCG test recently.
And I think I've had the call up in my colon that they said was pre-cancer for maybe four or five
years. So when I run my first HCG test, which was in 16, it was 52.2. Then in 17, it was 51.8. And now it's
I just got it done in February 51.4. And it's still an index plus four. I mean, like I really didn't
know how to read them. You know, they would say that's positive, but I don't really, I'm not sure.
So does that say anything to you? Does that mean anything to you or not? Well, you're just
wanted to go in the right direction. And we've had a lot of people do the Navarro test and it's
correlated really quite accurately with PET scans and CT scans and, you know, changes in the tour.
So we'll tell you if it's growing. So if your, if your, if your Navarro is dropping, that's a good
sign. So. Oh, okay, that's good. And then also since it's the end, let's see, my first, my
colonoscopy was, you know, that's safe. We're in a half years ago. And the, I had an eight,
is that millimeter polyp. And then, then in six months, I did vocal. I went to a vocal cancer
doctor in six months. I got, and I had another four millimeter polyp. And then I have, and that was
not with a colonoscopy. It was a sigmoidoscopy because I, you know, it was in the rectum. So anyway,
I haven't been back for anything since, you know, for like four, four, four and a half years. So I'm
thinking, it just may be a good idea. It just, you know, I just thought maybe a good idea for me to
go ahead and have another colonoscopy since I did have some problems. Does that sound? That only
thing. Now, when I had a colonoscopy, I have a really good doctor. So I didn't have anything,
you know, they didn't give me anything to make me sleepy. It was, it was really good. And it's just
a couple of pains, I guess, going around the corners. So the only thing that I would be doing
would be drinking all the things that I would need to drink to cleanse my colon. So do you think of
I think if it gives you a piece of mind, especially, too, I think there could be benefit of doing that. So
I, you know, I wouldn't hesitate to do that. You know, you're not doing a full one that could
damage your ascending colon or something like that. So
Okay. So do you, would you recommend then a sigmoidoscopy at the pet performance? Okay,
that's great then. I don't remember. I kind of think they don't have me drink that all that
if they do have me drink stuff to clear that up, would that be a problem?
Well, maybe see if you can argue against it. Okay. Okay, great.
Well, that stuff with burial, that's a heavy battle. That's not good for you.
Okay, well, this is really valuable. Okay, thank you. So I'm set on that. And then I had just posted
something. I was thinking that I guess I was in contact with Michelle. By the way, it's wonderful
to hear your voice. That was me who answered your Facebook post.
Oh, that was that year. Hello. So we'll have to see what you would like me to do for the next step
because I know that it is progressing and I'm not really happy because I've been really sharp,
that I'm more than I forget things. And then I can tell the I'm shaky too. I don't,
I don't get a good night's sleep. I go to bed too late. There's things that I need to be disciplined
and not be so stressed about. So, you know, there's like some lifestyle things that I need to do
that either way, I need to go in whatever, you know, I need to fix this.
All right, so I'll pull your file tomorrow and then either I'll contact you or I'll write up a
protocol at e-mail at you. Sure. Okay. Thank you very much. And then should it, can we can,
I heard you say something about updating rice programs. Is that something that we need to come
in to help you to do that? We could do that in a distance so that we can send you the flash drive
for you to put on your computer. So it makes it really easy for you. But I would like you to come in
because I haven't seen you for about a year. Well, you know, oh yes, so that's what I was going to ask.
Um, it's, I wouldn't expect you to come in. So you recommend us going in. Yeah, but I know
that life gets busy and it's hard to do that, so. Well, yeah, but I mean, this is our, our life or
death thing, you know, I just feel like if I do it right, I'll live longer and, you know,
George, too. Okay. So you do recommend us coming in. So when, um, is the weather really glad
at this time of the year, I guess? Whether it's beautiful tomorrow, it's supposed to be like two.
Okay. So when tomorrow, today is actually really nice. Today was in the high 20s. Tomorrow is a cold
who are getting a little cold stream come through. And it's only going to be about two degrees.
And then it's supposed to get back up into the high 20s again. Um, and then you really have to watch
the weather if you're like, oh, I want it to be about phrasing. You really have to watch it because
we can have a nice week that's, um, you know, with the 20s and 30s. And then we can all send it
and switch real quick and it could be 20 below. So. Okay. So what month does that go until when
August? Usually, usually by April that it's for sure going to be, you know, you can still get down
into the 30s, but usually it's in the 40s or 50s or 60s. So. Okay. So we'll just go ahead and
make plans. I think one time we were going to come in and it ended up to be snowy. So we had,
we had to cancel our freezing. I mean, like I see or snowy or something. We'll just go ahead and
schedule and appointment for us. And, um, okay. I still get that protocol put together and stuff.
So. Okay. So I'll go ahead and get my
signal and ask a P schedule. So then hopefully I can have that done before I see you too. I mean,
that's an idea. That would be great. Okay. Well, thank you. You are very welcome. Good to hear your
voice again. You're too. And we love, um, we just love everyone there. So. We're so. We're
in. We're all of you. So both thank you very much. And I'll talk to George about getting in then.
Okay. Okay. Bye. Bye. Bye. All right. Anybody other questions? All right. Thank you guys all
for today. It was a long day, but I think we was good because the people got some questions
after that. We haven't talked to it for a while. So we'll talk again next week. And again,
keep on Facebook. And if you don't, if you have more personal questions, post them on an email,
make sure you put a tagline in the email that it's Zoom call questions and send them into our email.
And we'll talk next week. All right. Bye bye. Bye. Thank you. Thank you.